[Music]
she's 17.
he i don't know i didn't hear what you
said that i was pronouns are he he they
oh he's 17.
yo i'm not cool
what does that mean you mean when your
parents are he he they
well it's michael jackson and a lot of
people
[Music]
you
no
that was so [ __ ] stupid
[Laughter]
that's a 10 out of 10.
that's a 10 out of 10.
don't ever ask me what that means
the minute you asked you knew i was
about to say something stupid because
you saw my face i was setting it up but
you came in with a home run [ __ ] bases
loaded
four walkers the team gave up
that was crazy that's funny
all right let's keep watching michael
jackson the jackson fight
i'm not gonna lie as michael jackson a
lot of people was funnier
all right so before we really get into
this video a little bit of context
basically somebody that is running for
senate in texas
essentially was coming to the school to
do a talk
and a bunch of protesters showed up some
of them apparently are not part of the
school but they felt some type of way
about his
anti-trained sentiments he's also the
same person you remember that story
about a father who was fighting his
ex-wife because their kid was
transitioning basically like she was
making her kid their kid
wear dresses while she the kid was at
her home but then when the kid was at
his father's home
other child would wear normal clothes
and so there was a big battle was all
over the news media remember that yeah
that's the same guy that's the same guy
okay so he's a focal point he's also
said some stuff that basically trans
folks don't exist et cetera et cetera so
shows up to the school and this is what
happens
[Music]
[Applause]
i think
the person was saying the gender was he
and he was a she
and the girl was he and they go she and
then the whole class goes he and he goes
she again i mean that's hip hop
he he he
he
she
we out here doing it with the dudes the
females the ladies we're coming through
with the babies the killers the babies
the babies the chinese the sadists the
baileys the dailies the baileys the
felonies
what this is what play that [ __ ] back
i'm in a hip-hop mode
we're the only two [ __ ] who could turn
a little bit of transphobia into hip-hop
yo hold up you know what i'm mark please
i'ma need you to make a song with me
right now yeah yeah yeah
don't this [ __ ] make a [ __ ] wanna act a
fool yes
okay jokes aside jokes right don't
decide me personally and i've said this
before i don't give a [ __ ] what gender
pronoun you want if you say you want to
be the identified t i'll use heal if you
want to say you want me to use she i you
she i don't give a [ __ ] i don't use the
zazen juror i don't use they okay but he
she i'm fine with all right
so me this is not an argument i would
ever get into someone says he i'm like
sure it's just like using whatever name
i don't give a [ __ ] so to me this is a
pointless little back and forth and i
haven't feel unnecessary just want to
say that is this [ __ ]
transferable to you yes
very when he says trans people don't
exist
my wife jenny you generally your
dysphoria is a real this is really okay
but let's keep watching
[Music]
[Applause]
she spit on me oh [ __ ] she took off her
mask
oh [ __ ] yeah that's hip-hop yeah
snatch master snap spit off don't feel
good all right
but yeah no more
i appreciate that in this classroom in
these covert times like half of them
have their mask on some of them don't
have their mask yeah so i'm going to
take their mask off to you know
something it's texas yeah they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah
there's something funny about a trans
woman saying suck my face i don't know
why didn't i remember i told you last
time when a trans person who says s my d
it hits a little different it is yeah
because you guys start thinking like but
how much have you transitioned really
that's none of my business it's not my
business
does it sound different
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you actually believe
that if someone disagrees with something
you can stand up and spit on them
that's the thing you can't ask for
respect if you disrespect
i agree but i definitely feel
disrespected
then i can't spit on somebody
if you if if yeah if you feel
disrespected
and then after that you come up and you
spit on somebody
that's assault
yeah you're gonna have to take off the
the head
just because it the shadows
that's the pop
the shadows hide your eyes that's why
there you go
that that that's the thing is that
he disrespected you yeah you don't have
to respect him yeah
he wants respect but he's disrespecting
everybody right but her she wants
respect she spits on someone you you up
the hand to your [ __ ]
that's that's that's assault but
but
your vex i can get it
i get that
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so
here's my thing and this is just me
personally i don't know how other folks
feel about it
i don't personally waste my time trying
to affirm myself to people who don't see
my humanity nah okay
i don't waste my time
like if i know someone's openly against
black folks i don't go up and start
yelling at them or trying to get them to
change their mind about me i'm like you
move your way i move my way
because me going out here screaming
right
or whatever is happening there it's a
waste of time
i'm not saying what he's saying is not
important it absolutely is i'm not with
it okay i don't bind to all that stuff
and i've said this pretty consistently
since the start but i also just don't
understand like in this instance like
it's more understandable because of how
reprehensible the person is but i've
seen these same kind of like protests
for like being jordan peterson or be it
for
some pharaoh he goes to university of
toronto they lose their mind like
rights look this this is what men's
rights look like this is what men's
rights looks like this is what men's
rights
[Applause]
[ __ ] you they're
[Applause]
[Music]
i just want to listen to someone else's
opinion i'm not even on a side here i
just list as many people as i can
i'm like these kind of campus protests
just make lefties look so stupid these
kind of protests and this kind of
yelling and like screaming and spitting
on people like honestly it's one of the
things that i see about like left folks
so i'm just like what are y'all doing
what is this i wanna waste my time with
some people that don't see my human not
my humanity there you go there's too
much like demanding that other people
conform to your way of viewing the world
and seeing things okay if it's not your
landlord if it's not your boss if it's
not your teacher or whatever keep it
pushing and you get what i'm saying like
they don't have to hold the same views
you they could be against gay marriage
they could be
four trans kids they could be four
whatever it doesn't matter like it's not
your place to go protest them all the
time but to me i just don't understand
that i don't i don't get that personally
yes don't get that
protesting for people that see humanity
like what malcolm x did or
what you mean mlk dude what do you mean
do you think you think malcolm x is
going to clan meetings and protesting
there no i said okay okay that's what
you yeah yeah i'm not saying don't fight
for your rights that's not what i said
yeah no no no no i see i just want to
clear it out yeah yeah and you
yeah so somebody's like anti-immigrants
or like if there's like a person like to
me go into that and be like yo
i know to me is a waste of time yeah
that's what you're saying unless they're
a congressman or whatever but then again
i guess this guy is appealing for senate
so maybe that does make a bit of sense
you know he is going for
a real official seat
in government so maybe this does make
sense in that context i guess so i can
understand people going against them you
know i mean
but
yeah talking to someone yelling at
someone [ __ ] you that doesn't
he's not gonna
respect you more
it's not gonna change his mind by this
point i don't think the [ __ ] you was
meant to change his mind
that you know [ __ ] you and if he was
more shrewd with his language which a
lot of politicians are people who are
against your movement you would have
just come out looking stupid if you
would have not said this stuff about
like i don't believe in trans folks he
would have been more diplomatic about it
and just been like actually smart about
the way he engaged with this though you
would have been the one that looks at it
so you have to understand the ways in
which your tactics don't translate well
to the average person because even as
abhorrent as he is right or whatever
issues he's got it doesn't reflect well
on you personally or the individuals who
attend these things persons like antifa
and people think they're fighting for
such a good cause but the way they do
[ __ ] is like what it's yes it's like
that woman who was outside the transfer
yeah they were trying to respond and
then they were all surrounding her
they were going to fight a cis woman
for
somebody who actually diddled kids yeah
i'm like what are y'all doing mm-hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you can walk away get the [ __ ] out right
and so you have to just be careful what
it is that you're doing and how you're
doing it
because at the end of the day how you
deliver something matters
but then again that's up to you really
yeah but i'm just talking about the
cause
because it makes me cringe to identify
as a lefty person just in terms of my
personal politics and my beliefs when i
see how a lot of the left engages in
conversations and stuff like this you
know what i'm saying it's like the trans
women trans women in sports yeah these
[ __ ] are just saying oh you
came in 17th not 16th well you're a
[ __ ] loser so why are you complaining
about the trans woman taking your spot
or they're saying stuff like who cares
if you weren't good enough to make it
with a trans woman president then what
does it matter it's like you're stealing
scholarship whole work life
opportunities from athletes like not
everything is about placing the top
three some of it is just about being
even in the race itself that's a huge
honor for people who go to the olympics
they know a lot of them are not going to
win
but the honor of being in the olympic
village to represent your country
proudly to be able to compete in that
kind of stage where everyone is actually
watching athletics with intention
experience and stuff it's it's
life-changing and so when i see left
engages like dishonest well [ __ ] women's
sports who needs anyways i'm like really
people
and so it's like what i'm seeing with
like a lot of this stuff is that the way
that they engage with this stuff
is like violence
it's violent or extremist
and i don't identify with that even
though my politics left do you get what
i'm saying
and so i'm just like
i don't even like probably even saying
it out loud anymore because they make me
cringe so hard that doesn't say that the
right doesn't have issues or whatever
but you can speak to this me and you the
people we deal with on a day-to-day
basis basis who are they
the people that we deal with they
left leading folks right most
where we're in the arts
so yes
even as minorities as a minority yeah
right so um left leading when it comes
to racial issues and in terms of how
they vote and how they identify yes left
i don't know too many of them that would
identify as right when you're a
conservative yeah left right so
we see it all the time so it's much
closer to us so i don't know for me it
just makes me cringe a lot more
because of that mm-hmm
but they they they do exactly they do
exactly what they they go against like
yeah you shouldn't do this you shouldn't
do that but that's how they go you
should have more discourse and then they
don't let people talk yeah they don't
they're not open to this course it's
just like that they're not open to you
know conversation and [ __ ]
what was he doing there
he's having like a little talk with the
people there
i don't even know why you stayed that
long
i mean i think you want to catch this i
think he thinks it's good for him
i'm just like ugh
i would have left i'd have been like
okay
i'm out
you guys are just being yelled at and
[ __ ] like that yeah
it's not a conversation but then again
but then again he kind of have what he
deserved because yeah [ __ ] are
being super strength transforming and
being abrasive yeah but hey that's just
my thoughts on it what do you guys think
in the comments below i'm sure a lot of
you guys disagree with our stance or
agree with his or disagree with all of
everybody
let us know why all right